best for soil green manures and cover
crops practical information hello my
name is Michaela and I breed cover crops
and green manures in this video you will
learn how to grow cover crops and green
manures and why they are an important
tool in improving soil health cover
crops are cultivated between the harvest
of one main crop and the sowing of the
next main crop the main reasons to grow
cover crops are to protect the soil
against erosion to increase soil
fertility to improve soil structure to
facilitate water infiltration and to
retain nutrients in the upper soil
horizon there are several terms for this
growing practice and they can be used in
more or less the same sense however
there can be some specific differences
in crop management depending on what
your primary reason for growing the
cover crop is when cover crops are
incorporated into the soil they are
usually termed green manures catch crops
are used to avoid nutrient loss
particularly nitrogen leaching many
different species are used as cover
crops each has specific advantages and
requirements
some are frost resistant and survive the
winter
others freeze down easily nutrients
taken up by green manure crops are
returned to the soil to be utilized by
the following crop a well-informed
choice of cover crops improves crop
rotations cover crops with a pathogen
susceptibility different from the major
crops in the rotation decreases the
overall potential of soil borne diseases
the best for soil databases are powerful
tools to determine which cover crops
best fit into a crop rotation root
exudates
and additional organic matter provided
by cover crops can stimulate soil
microbial activity and influence the
composition of the microbial community
in the soil both factors stabilize and
boost the microbial community which in
turn may reduce pressure from soil borne
diseases one major group of cover crops
are grass species including some closely
related to cereal crops they are
fast-growing and some species will grow
even at low temperatures seed for these
crops is easily available in all regions
of Europe grass cover crops can not only
be used as green manure but also for
grazing or feeding animals most grass
species are winter hardy another
important group of cover crops are
Brassica species they are especially
fast-growing and are therefore good at
suppressing weed populations some are
used to decreased disease incidence in
cereal rich rotations some to avoid
nitrogen leaching some of the brassicas
cover crops are winter hardy while some
are frost sensitive another advantage of
Brassica species are their deep rooting
tap roots which help improve the soil
structure the Jumana species have the
advantage of fixing nitrogen and
therefore providing this important
nutrient to the following main crop
several legume species are used as cover
crops ranging from small seeded clover
to medium-sized veg up to farber beans
with big sized seeds the zoomed
performed best when established early in
the season and are mostly used in a
mixture with other cover crops there are
several fast-growing species commonly
used as cover crops such as phacelia
buckwheat or marigold detailed
information on all of these species is
published in a best for soil fact sheet
cover crops require the same careful
cultivation as main crops a
well-prepared seed bed is essential for
a successful cover crop nitrogen
application is particularly important
guaranteeing a vigorous cover crop
however similar to main crops the
nitrogen left by the previous crop has
to be taken into account
the preparation of the seed bed is
essential to ensure a rapid and
consistent establishment of the crop it
should be adapted to the specific needs
of the seed healthy seeds with a high
germination rate should be used to
ensure successful establishment of the
crop irrigation might be needed for
crops grown in summer especially for
fast-growing species such as mustards or
sorghum selected cultivars should be
resistant to the most relevant diseases
and pests in the region where they are
cultivated
some cultivars have specific traits such
as containing secondary metabolites
which can have a bio fumigation effect
more information on biofilm ocation are
available in a specific video and fact
sheet some cover crops or cultivars will
die off during winter which helps
facilitate their incorporation into the
soil the following spring such cultivars
are not suitable as green manure in the
spring as they will decompose before
their incorporation in spring on the
other hand cover crops grown in summer
especially in southern Europe have to be
heat tolerant therefore the choice of
cultivars adapted to the local climatic
conditions is critically important as
cover crops can also be host plants for
soil borne diseases their selection has
to fit the crop rotation of the major
crops cultivated to generate income
grass species fit especially well in
vegetable production systems where no
grass related species are grown
Brassica species are better suited for
rotations with arable crops where with
the exception of oil seed rape normally
no Brassica species are grown in
contrast they don't fit well in
vegetable production systems especially
in northern europe where many Brassica
vegetables are grown finally and most
importantly the choice of cover crop or
green manure depends on the primary
reason its own in the first place reduce
soil borne diseases avoid nitrogen
leaching protect from erosion increase
organic matter regardless the
compatibility of cover crops with the
rotation of the major crops has to be
checked with the help of the best for
soil databases
you